hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapters 15 and 16 of this monologue
insane and some is engaged in the
process clarifying for us his readers
what it is that can be said
substantively about the divine substance
or that is God what does it mean to
speak substantively it means to say what
that thing is not just to mean the
attributes of it or you might say
accidental or contingent things that
happen to be for example in talking
about me you might say well dr. Sandler
has long hair right but I can shake it
off and as a matter of fact I've been
bald at other points the same thing with
a beard you can actually find pictures
of me lacking both of those at one time
I was not as tall as I was and I suppose
I'll probably lose a few pinches as I
age and the bone cell is there's all
sorts of things along those lines what
does it mean for me to be this substance
this this person well now we're asking
this now about something that we
you know look at and we've got so much
sense experience with or even reflective
experience you know thinking about
ourselves but the the divine substance
itself so what can be said about and
some tells us some really interesting
things here the first is that he says
with respect to relatives relative terms
what does he mean by that father and son
or another example would be bigger than
or smaller than these are relative terms
colder than and hotter than right
they're relational he says no one doubts
that none of them is said substantially
of the thing of which it is sent
relatively that that's that makes
perfect sense these are relational terms
even if they have two substances or two
things - two beings in order to relate
them to each other and the relation is
for things like that the relation is
posterior is afterwards it's not
ontologically prior to the things
themselves so he says if someone said
relatively of the supreme nature if
something is said relatively the supreme
nature it doesn't signify its substance
so what would this include you know
saying that god is the god of the exodus
or something like that you know we're
talking about contingent events that are
recorded in a text and yes there's
something that's being shown about the
nature of God in them but God presumably
could have chosen to do things
differently so they are saying something
important and they're saying something
interesting but they're not saying
something about the divine substance and
divine substance now in some points out
two very interesting terms that this
will apply to supreme we've been talking
about of the divine substance in terms
of the supreme good
Supreme Being as it turns out those
don't actually name the divine substance
in its substantiality they are they are
indeed true things to say according to
an some about the divine substance but
they don't get at what precisely it is
and we'll see how we can do that that
later what else greater than now why is
this an issue well they had some points
out if none of those things created
things in relation to which the divine
substance is said to be supreme or
greater had ever existed then the divine
substance would not be understood as
supreme or greater so I you know I think
about this is a little bit of stretch
before creation before when it's just
God by God's self you know we know that
for an some God is a Trinity but that
that complicates things a bit more to
bring that up at this point so before
anything else is created is the Supreme
Being supreme
no because supreme is a term which is
relative to other things so you can't be
supreme if you're all by yourself it's
just a you know a term that doesn't mean
anything
in that case say anything with greater
than can't be greater than anything
until you've got something else to be
greater to that similarly it can't be
less than anything right employees
something else that you could be less
than so if that's the case then these
words these terms these concepts don't
really signify what the divine substance
is in itself so he says if these you
know other things didn't exist God would
not on that account be any less good and
as essential greatness would be in no
way be diminished so in some points out
as well then this is leading us towards
what's going to happen
in chapter 16 this is because God has
God's being from himself
xa and per se not from anything else and
we cite him in the previous video so you
can take a look at those but what all of
that means for Ansem so supreme does not
signify that essence greater does not by
itself signify than essence so how could
we then say what it is that God is so
Anselm engages in some more reflections
about language at this point he says
having to dismiss those things that are
said relatively let us turn our
attention to other things that must be
discussed indeed if one looks carefully
at each of them whatever there is other
than relatives is either such that
whatever that is in the Latin gypsum the
thing itself these in every respect
better than not whatever that is or such
that not whatever it is isn't some
respect better than what that it is so
for example to be made a short great
thing for trock means that I can write
on the chalkboard with it would it be
good for my video camera to be made of
charge they have that quality of truck
eNOS no because it wouldn't work that as
a video camera would it be good for my
glasses to be made of chalk they
couldn't give very good glasses what
about my body so see in certain respects
it's good to be made of chalk for
certain things it's good in certain
respects it's better for the chalk to be
man chalk then they'd be made of
graphite or whatever these glasses are
made of whatever plastics are in them
but it's not good you know without a
qualification you might say so are there
things then that are you know in every
respect better to be than not to be if
there are such things those tell us what
the divine substance
that's TV was on and he says that some
things are such that in every respect it
is better to be that thing than not to
be that thing for example it is better
to be wise than to be not wise and you
might say well you know what about you
know if ignorance is bliss or you know
things like that Ansel doesn't really
buy that genuine true wisdom in its
fullest sense is going to be a good a
good that trumps anything that is
deprived of wisdom now certain things
aren't going to be able to receive
wisdom we've got a piece of chalk not a
sentient being my dog not as a sentient
being but it's not capable of wisdom we
can quit a little bit when we get to the
very high animals about what Ansel might
say about them given better data than he
had at the time but as it stands wisdom
is something that we can in fact
predicate about the divine substance it
is better to be wise than not to be wise
so you know he gives an example of your
since a just person who is not wise
seems to be better than a wise person
who's not just it's not better than an
unqualified sense to be not wise than to
be wise indeed whatever is not wise in
an unqualified sense is less is not as
good doesn't it in a certain way doesn't
have as much be it as whatever is wise
and so he says it's in every respect
better to be true than not to be true
it's just better to be just than not to
be just it's also better to be living
than not living and he will talk about a
number of different possibilities for
this towards the end some of the upshot
of this before we get to that listing is
that we can say that God is not certain
things for example in chapter 15 and
some will say okay this allows us to say
that God is not a body God is not
something corporeal and put aside
worries about the second
the Trinity that will come up that's
that's for a different text right but
the divine substance is not something
bodily why because if it was it would
not be unqualifiedly you know better as
that then not to be them in some cases
it is better for body for something to
be a body right truck it only exists as
a body I have a body you do too if
you're home that's unless you're you
know in the future somewhere and perhaps
some artificial intelligence but even an
artificial intelligence has a corporeal
frame too doesn't it but you see what
this allows it permits certain possible
misidentifications to be stripped away
doesn't have a positive import as well
yes this allows us to say that God is
indeed whatever it is better to be than
not to be he says he must therefore this
is the divine substance be living
there's one quality wise powerful and
all-powerful true just happy eternal and
whatever similarly it is absolutely
better to be than not to be so you know
we might have have worries or concerns
about whether it is indeed better to be
each of these things than to be an some
has you know reasons for why he says
that not given here in this just some
passages but you can see what he's doing
with that
so that's chapter 15 what happens then
in chapters 16 well we've now come up
with a set of names or attributes for
the divine substance right we just
rattled them up living and wise powerful
true just happy so these are things that
we can say about gap now what happens
when we are saying things like that
we're talking usually in terms of
qualities or in terms of
quantities within Anselm's neil patel
christian Neoplatonic metaphysical
framework those refer us back to
whatever it is that they participated so
if we want to say that one person is
more just than another person we're
making a sort of quantitative or perhaps
a qualitative but probably quantitative
you know determination there and we're
saying that that that person was more
just participates in justice in whatever
justice happens to be could be the form
of justice could be something else but
they participated then when we did a
video about this this particular
metaphysical assumption so if you want
to know more about that we'll check out
that core concept video now that works
for creative beings according to
handsome so I am sentient for example I
am living I have those qualities does it
work to say this about the divine
substance
Ansem says no well why well let's look
at it is his discussion here he says
that it would be then it would be the
case that the supreme nature is just
precisely through justice so it seems
that the supremely good substance is
said to be just in virtue of
participation and equality namely
justice but if that is the case then the
supreme substance the the divine
substance is not actually just in itself
it's just through another and and some
has rejected this through another this
is what it means for God to be per se
God has the attributes that God has or
rather is the being that God is through
God so he says this is contrary to the
clearly discern truth that whatever he
is but he is through himself and not
through another so if God then is not
what God is through another he has to be
that through himself what would this
mean in terms of these qualities well
like I put here if we think in terms of
the example that Anselm uses which is
justice God does not have justice the
way that we have justice when we're just
similarly God does not have being God
does not have truth God does not have
reason God is those things God is
justice since this is the example that
Anselm uses let's actually take a look
at his verbiage here and see what he
says he says there's some wonderful
passages if somebody asks what does the
supreme nature you're discussing what
true answer could be given then justice
not something that has justice but just
justice so he says that the human being
can that be justice but he can have
justice so you know just human being is
not understood as what an some calls
exist in the Justice that is in Latin
quite quite you know literally your skin
yet existence
standing out existing being as justice
itself the way that justice does the
human being cannot do that but the
Supreme Being exists as justice
similarly it does with these other
things that we call the divine
attributes these qualities that are you
know things that are better to be
unqualifiedly than not to be so he says
when somebody asks what what God is just
is no less fitting an answer than
justice they says whatever you know
worse for justice in this way applies to
all the other things that are said of
the supreme nature in a similar way
whichever of them is said of him
designates neither what sort of thing he
is nor how great he is so those would be
you know qualities and quantities what
sort of thing how great right but rather
to these things
know what in fact the divine substance
yes so what is the divine substance the
Ansem gives us this entire interesting
listing here he says he is supreme
essence they were being essentia supreme
life Veta supreme reason gratia supreme
salvation solvus supreme justice am i
going to give you any more life in here
supreme wisdom supreme truth supreme
goodness greatness beauty immortality
improved ability immutability the
attitude eternity power unity and they
says which is none other than supremely
being supremely living and other things
so what we have here is a treatment of
the divine attributes the anselm is
answering the question when we predicate
these attributes of God what are we
actually saying are we are we saying God
is this kind of thing or God has this to
to a greater degree than other beings no
we're actually saying God is that very
thing that we're talking about this is
difficult to wrap one's head around but
remember the mobile own kid is supposed
to be a meditation it's not supposed to
be just something that you pick up like
that and suddenly it all totally makes
sense this is something you have to kind
of mall over and think about if you're
actually going to find it acceptable or
meaningful but you may not but that is
the Anschluss position on what can be
said about God